have you ever been amazed by how google
home and amazon alexa assist in finding
information when asked over voice or
have you ever wondered how e-commerce
companies send you personalized emails
for shopping suggestions based on the
products that you bought online recently
well it's all because of machine
learning that these virtual assistants
and product recommendations work swiftly
in this video we're going to look at
machine learning roadmap for 2022.
we will give you this step-by-step
process that you need to follow to build
a successful career in machine learning
so before we get started make sure that
you subscribe to the simply learn
channel and hit the bell icon to never
miss an update from simplylearn so what
is machine learning
machine learning is a subset of
artificial intelligence that uses data
algorithms and statistical techniques to
build intelligent systems
these systems learn by themselves and
improve with experience
the goal of machine learning is to
create computer models that can imitate
human behavior machine learning has
found its usage in almost every business
sector
from self-driving cars medical imaging
and diagnostics speech recognition
facial recognition to online fraud
detection all of these are possible
because of machine learning
in recent years ai and ml technologies
have made several breakthroughs and the
rising demand for ai applications across
different industries has led to the
significant growth of machine learning
as for markets and markets.com the
machine learning market is expected to
grow to 9 billion by 2022
at ac agr of 44
another report from verified market
research.com suggests that the machine
learning market was valued at 2.4
billion us dollars in 2019 and is
projected to reach 47.29 million usc by
2027
growing at a cagr of 44.9 percent from
2020 to 2027.
keeping these facts and forecasts in
mind let's look at the roadmap and
critical skills required to build a
career in machine learning
first and foremost is programming skills
for a machine learning engineer
programming languages form the building
blocks to develop complex machine
learning models
you need to learn at least one
programming language preferably python
or r
you should be familiar with various
computer science concepts such as data
structures including stack cues trees
and graphs
algorithms for searching and sorting
dynamic and greedy programming space and
time complexity etc you also need to
know libraries like numpy pandas
matplotlib seaborn d player tidier and
ggplot for data analysis and
visualization
the second skill you need to possess is
applied mathematics
while solving business problems using
machine learning you have to use machine
learning algorithms
to understand the mechanisms behind the
algorithms you need to have a good
knowledge of mathematical concepts such
as linear algebra calculus statistics
and probability
so mathematics and machine learning is
not just processing the numbers but
understanding what is happening why it's
happening and how to obtain the best
results the third skill to become a
machine learning expert is
data wrangling and sql
data analysts and machine learning
specialists often work with raw data
collected from various sources that are
not fit for analysis
it has been observed that 80 percent of
data analysis spend too much time on
data wrangling
so it's crucial for machine learning
experts to clean structure and enrich
raw data into desired format and make it
ready for analysis using data wrangling
techniques
sql is another crucial set that you
should carry
machine learning tasks involve using
data stored in the form of tables that
are present inside relational databases
a good understanding of sql commands
enables you to store manipulate retrieve
and handle structured data
the next skill set is machine learning
algorithms it's incredibly essential to
grasp all the standard machine learning
algorithms
implementing any machine learning
techniques requires choosing the
suitable model determining the correct
learning method and an in-depth
understanding of hyper parameter tuning
so you should be really good with
different supervised unsupervised and
reinforcement learning algorithms such
as linear regression logistic regression
svm knn decision trees k means
clustering etc now coming to the final
scale we have data modeling and
evaluation the objective of a machine
learning engineer is to train the best
performing model possible
depending on the problem at hand you
will need to choose a suitable error
measure and an evaluation strategy for a
machine learning model
the most vulnerable part of a machine
learning candidate's resume is the
absence of experience working on diverse
machine learning projects
with all the essential skills acquired
you can now build an impressive machine
learning portfolio highlighting some
exciting machine learning projects
machine learning engineers need a
portfolio that showcases their expertise
to implement machine learning techniques
to real-world problems
with your resume ready you can now look
for the best machine learning jobs in
top product companies and startups
you can become a machine learning
engineer a data scientist a data analyst
or a research scientist
some of the top companies hiring for
machine learning roles are google amazon
ibm uber graminer navidia and linkedin
machine learning engineers are some of
the highest paid professionals in the
world
according to glassdoor.com the national
average salary for machine learning
engineers in the united states is one
lakh 31 000 us dollars per year in india
you can earn nearly 8 lakh rupees per
annum
this salary may vary based on your
experience the industry you are applying
for and the company policy
there are immense opportunities in
machine learning for sectors such as
e-commerce manufacturing logistics
retail and healthcare
if you are interested in a career in
machine learning then start your journey
now with simplylearn's postgraduate
program in ai and machine learning that
is in partnership with purdue university
and in collaboration with ibm
you will learn all the in-demand machine
learning skills and work on programming
with hands-on examples
the program also offers job assistance
to know more about the learning part
tools covered and projects that you will
be working on please click on the course
page link in the description below
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here